[Applause]
wow they're a little subdued tonight
yeah yeah not a good crowd tonight
that was fantastic first of all uh
congratulations
on the emmy win last night best drama
series
we're uh we're so proud of that because
it means that every single person who
works on the show both in in albuquerque
and here in los angeles and the folks in
new york the studio the network
everybody has a piece of that victory
and that's that's what we're really
happy about
also it was clear to me when i went
backstage to say hi that you guys have
been partying hard
for 24 hours he just got in yeah
he's now rolled in from all the parties
right he has no
idea who i am right now
yo [ __ ] yo [ __ ]
[Applause]
we have so much ground to cover so much
to talk about aaron what i love is that
idiots like me and everyone in the press
has been asking you guys for months
what's going to happen what's going to
happen what's going to happen your stock
answer is
everyone dies that's what you've been
saying
explain that because just just tell me
how it ends just who dies
does walt die does jessie die do they
kill each other and then finally she's
like listen everyone
just everyone dies this is an easy easy
way out
does that bother people when you tell
them that yes
the only one is true though yeah yeah
it's true for every occasion
yeah the only one who stays alive is
holly and so we have a sequel
you know holly white the story continues
the year she has a little gun
baby heisenberg ah baby heisenberg
now brian one of the revelations of this
show uh for you as an actor is that
you're such a
a nice guy you're such a sweet presence
you're so amiable
but man you have a scary face when you
want to have a scary
when you want to have a scary face i
don't know how you do it well i
it's funny you should mention that
because i always thought that even
no emotion whatsoever i have a scary
face period
so if for instance okay if i'm looking
at this camera no emotion whatsoever
the the the thing that you read is fear
that's fantastic it's terrifying yeah is
that work for everybody
it works well let's but what is what is
the one word that you
sense when you look in no emotion
whatsoever
completely devoid
[Applause]
it's just a bit of sadness i'm just
i feel like i'm not getting enough
oxygen
it just makes nothing it's like you wet
yourself
that's just andy let's see yours yeah
what am i looking at
well the one with the red light no
emotion at all
none whatsoever
you look angry he looks like an angry
principal you're goddamn right
now
i'm not trying do anything wipe it all
away
oh that's sweet look
i got a guy i was getting a guy thinking
about lunch that's what i was getting